god bless you my friend what is your
first name
joe
joe my ass joe
during world war ii they were all joe
you're a jew you got to be with that
knows if you're not you're an eagle i'll
tell you this
my what sorry were you willing at school
was i bullied at school
no
what did you do for a living so you
might be asking
you're a student what are you studying
you're still in secondary school in
ireland
and what do you want to be when you grow
up
dan how about you guys right here where
do you guys meet up
good friends
but the [ __ ] it but we're all rooting
for him now are we
that's how it goes she's like we're just
two cute friends with
baby faces who are drinking a lot of
alcohol together
you never know what could happen
good friends for real recently separated
really oh you used today
oh my god
[Applause]
you you're you were married
you were three kids
not together
this really is complicated this
you have three kids
but you were you were married and you're
no longer married
this is like the usual suspects i've
never been so confused in my life
wait no but you but you just got
separated and she had three kids
you have three kids
you should have sex with them just for
happiness
just for having to have three kids
how old are you
23.
did you ever think of coming in your
hand or something because
what the hell
you're 23
didn't you have dreams
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's i take it back don't [ __ ] him he
doesn't know what to do with it
that's crazy
dad three kids at 23.
you did two
we get it you're the midwest jesus
is here to do how old are you
it's your birth happy birthday what are
you drinking tonight
why get her get her wine on me for a
birthday come on
what
and hey
and hey
get this guy whatever the hell he wants
all night
because he [ __ ] his life up
would you raise her would you rise
japanese no chinese chinese sure since
the water all chinese
how pregnant sweetheart
seven and a half months ah we're gonna
get a leg out of that thing tonight for
sure dude
one hard laugh a foot is popping out
guaranteed that's what i'm going for i'm
not happy unless i see digits
is that the pops behind you right there
ask what's up what are you bro you black
what
you mexican bro
how you how you grow a full beard bro
mexicans can't do that [ __ ]
mexican full beard
damn dude
you might as well just be muslim dog
just [ __ ] convert
just convert your face already converted
for you
second and beard here is proud of you
like adios buddy
is the way way
nashville y'all need some mexicans all
these unfinished ass buildings bro
every [ __ ] building bro like
[Applause]
come on
what's your name mexican with a beard
anthony how you say beard in spanish you
don't know because they don't have that
word [ __ ] because
mexicans don't have beards you know how
to say mustache be got that way
is that your guy's first kid
you look like you're in good there's no
disrespect but you look like you're in
good shape you're i don't know how to
say this but like you're kind of hot
is that weird i can't sierra is that
weird to say
not like you know pregnant women can be
beautiful obviously they're beautiful
but like i'm saying i'm fine with it
no this is fat candy no disrespect i
just i see why you left it in you know
[Applause]
[Laughter]
did i ask if you had another kid yet i
didn't do you yeah so this is the this
is the one that's coming out
boy
let's go
that [ __ ] coming right out
he mexican he's like is there a miracle
on the other side of this
[Laughter]
i'm not that way
i'm gonna lasso that
treat that umbilical cord
[Applause]
i'm excited for you guys are you guys a
little scared too
you're not scared at all sweetheart
really how old are you
39 oh so you were like we got to do this
this [ __ ] is
[Music]
yo it who's only a mexican you could get
a 39 year old pregnant bro let me tell
you that's some super sperm right there
you needed that [ __ ]
white dick not getting 39 pregnant yo
uh uh white dick not bro that mexicans
burn bro that's the red shell from mario
kart sinus
i will find the egg
my sperm come out like the banana peels
oh my vape pen
you want to hit my vape pen
oh sorry [ __ ] i'm trying not to get
herpes my back
no disrespect i'm not saying you have
herpes i'm just saying
one out of five people do so let's just
uh
let's just all be careful around this
[ __ ] make sure that
we leave with the lips we came with
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
good luck to you i spoke to the people
in bethlehem they expect you
anyway
that's that's that's bethlehem steel no
that's the new thing for young people
that's the way they have to express
themselves and good luck to you son
what's your name son
jeff ko wonderful
it's the new hand shaky that he's trying
to pin me
nice to see you what do you do for a
living jeff nothing nothing
say hello to vern winger he works in
cold storage
who brought in this crowd is there a bad
bus someplace
good luck to you though jeff don't do
anything just sit around wait for a
barber strike
good for john jeffrey
i do ma'am and what is your name sylvia
sylvia oh when your last name colas
sylvia kolas and that's mr colas and
you're a shriner nice to see you shriner
here and where are you from mr colas los
angeles wonderful nice to see what do
you do for a living mr colas i'm an
optometrist oh wonderful i hope it goes
away
maybe that would be all right for you an
optometrist
better than sitting around on the beach
all day waiting for birds to die
hello mother how are you i call you
mother because bless you i could see
you're full of life that's beautiful to
life that's the main thing and where you
from my darling los angeles and your
last name is what moss moss
and that's your husband how many is you
married don't ask
is that your is that your dad with you
sir good all right and that's your
you're the dad i'm thinking of those two
kids
nice what's your name dad
jay and uh what are your boys names
what
zade or zane
zade with a d and then tarik and then
you're
j
am i the only one to notice is an
inconsistency here
that's better all right jay
and where are you from
oh from jordan okay i've been there
i got some friends there
and how old are your boys
17 and 14. why does 14 look older than
you for some reason
a 14 year old arab kid is like the
equivalent to a 23 year old white kid do
you realize that
[Laughter]
wow and so this is what you decided to
do jay bring him to see me
what happened
you're
you live in houston
okay
yeah i know i get it
i'll get back to you later when you
when your english processor catches up
again
no we live in houston
[Laughter]
good it's a good place for indian people
to pretend they're mexican that's nice
get away with a little bit of both out
here
what's your name bro
what
imran
okay
where's your family from imran
pakistan oh okay so you're indian
um
[Applause]
not till you're 100 will you be
pakistani all right um
and who's with you tonight imran
your wife or your wives you're allowed
many i mean
the one beside you is your wife and
that's her friend
hi friend and wife how are you
sucks when you have to have two on one
wife one friend cause
i'm not friends with my wife but that's
my friend this is my wife
how long have you two been married for
15 years wow and where were you raised
in england all right you didn't get all
you know he didn't sound english until
he said it did you realize that he was
like
in england
and when did you move to america
12 years ago so
are you from england too then wife
where are you from
new york
but you've been married 15 years
and he's been here 12.
you're not from houston are you
[Laughter]
so you got married and then waited for
the paperwork to show up
or did you go to england for three years
you went to england for three years what
part of england
what part of london
what
london
i feel like i feel like leicester london
what part
king kingston
kingston lovely
and were you born in london
and then you moved to america
right
and
what's your name wife
anika
wasn't that just a mispronunciation of a
nike those are the kind of nikes my
parents would buy when i was a kid we
cannot afford real nike here's anika